let me pull up the story we got from the
washington post this is uh relatively
nebulous i suppose justice department
investigating trump's actions
in january 6 criminal probe people
familiar with the probe said
investigators are examining the former
president's conversations and seized
phone records of top aides what they
don't say is
is trump the target of this criminal
probe no the washington post post just
says trump's actions that that doesn't
even say they're investigating trump
himself they may be passively referring
to well trump said this one thing what
does that have to do with it and i
guarantee you right now there's a panel
on msnbc wringing their hands and john
dean's on there talking about you know
sort of his experience with nixon it's
it's just a you know and i mean it's
just it's it's it's a trail of of morons
quite frankly that that then will jump
on a story like that and and immediately
wildly speculate
not only as to that trump is the target
they'll say not knowing and then
they will
usually uh immediately convict him and
you know suggest you know again say the
worst possible things about him it's
it's got to be infuriating well so this
this is this is never ending i mean
russiagate was a farce it was a hoax
how come none of these people are being
held to account mm-hmm i mean
high-ranking individuals signing off on
this stuff
look you're you know you were uh i think
you were in for about how long were you
for about a year as acting ag uh four
months four months much less i spanned
two uh 2018 and 2019 so okay yeah looks
better on my resume right that must be
what i saw well so i'm wondering in your
in your experience then i mean you're
you're there at asag why isn't
why isn't why hasn't anyone done
anything about this i mean do you think
if if trump wins in 2024 maybe there
will be some accountability for for the
lies i mean i hope when you had cash on
here he talked about his his durham
watch and you know sort of what john
durham is or isn't doing uh you saw how
difficult the michael sussman
prosecution were i mean it was very
clear that that that he had lied to the
fbi and and a jury in the district of
columbia is never going to convict you
know right
somebody in that situation well so i
mean that goes back to my death penalty
comments yeah right you get you get
someone who's a trump supporter
suspected of a very serious heinous
crime you put him in dc they're gonna be
like kill him yeah that's horrifying uh
and and that's that two-tier system of
justice is something that i'm i'm
talking about a lot right now we have um
there's no doubt that the left
it gets away you know you think about
the riots in 2020 and compare that to
january 6. um you know you i'm sure that
um you know some smart lawyer could
could parse the difference but but it's
really not it's it's political violence
yep um you know if those people outside
the white house that burn you know the
church
uh right across the street from the
white house if they had you know they
were trying to get into the white house
you know they had to build dramatic you
know sort of night after night they kept
trying to push the perimeter out first
of all and build higher fences to keep
those folks i mean there were police
officers were assaulted uh you know
there was no doubt about that during
those riots and so so and no i don't i
mean again i i'm i'm going to make a
bold statement here but but certainly
those folks that participated in that
over the course of the summer in
washington dc and looted georgetown and
and just you know you know
did all sorts of of things
nobody was prosecuted to the extent that
the people that participated in january
6. and i'm saying both those should be
treated the same like political violence
is never acceptable but in this case the
american people see the different
treatment of those folks i i've talked
to people they have no idea what 529 is
i mean we i talk to people all the time
and i say you know what are your
thoughts on when they try when the 529
you know riots when they set fire to a
guard post when they torched the church
and tore the barricades down the
president was forced into bunker they go
i didn't know that happened no because
the media you know well there's a 529
commission i mean right
yeah no no no no but and that's my point
before the show you mentioned that at
some point it's just not worth it to get
paid 170 000 a year to have your life
destroyed by the establishment by the
union party by the democrats and so i
wonder if that's the reason why you
don't get a 529 commission why
republicans seem to do very little if
anything at all yeah
well i think you know in
the next year um i expect that there
will be a lot more i mean i think the
the right is learning that we can't sit
by and play you know patty cake while
the left tries to destroy literally
uh our entire society and people you
know everybody's reputation i mean i
think there is just a finally final
realization that
we can't
not fight uh you know we'd prefer to
actually um you know have a civil
dialogue and have a discussion and have
the marketplace of ideas that's supposed
to work and convince people to you vote
for us and vote against them but but i
think there is a realization now that
the left is just in it to win it and not
only to win it but but but like destroy
everything in their path for for the
sake of power but there's there's see
you know when uh
you're you're acting a g i mean they
came after you pretty hard i'd imagine
right yeah
absolutely republicans don't do that to
democrats there's
look at brett kavanaugh i mean the
psychotic behavior they accused the man
of lining up at frat parties to
gang
assault women yeah in these ridiculous i
wasn't seeing some pirate ship going up
and down the coast wasn't there some
story about that i mean it was just it
was like nonsense someone literally
fabricated a story about him on some
boat doing something to a woman and then
they were like yeah we made the whole
thing up
where are the republicans accusing
democrats of doing anything they don't
and then when when you get people like
james lindsey for instance and he starts
referring to people targeting children
as groomers twitter bans the word and
big tech comes in immediate defense of
the left so there's no collateral damage
for the democrats and the left to engage
in this behavior the right does not do
anything to combat it and so you look at
the republican party i mean half the
time they're in agreements or or look at
this we just had how many republicans
come out supporting gun control
which is wildly unpopular among the
republican voter base they don't care
you know i look at people like shelley
shelly moore capital in west virginia
she's not of a re-election for another
like five years so so what does she care
she's probably laughing all the way to
the bank as she torches her constituents
this is what we keep getting so i mean
man is it brutal to watch yeah now now
you have the january 6 committee on tv
they're calling it a tv show the season
finale they're lying about basically
everything
and people are are wrapped up in this
cult they believe this stuff
and you know
there's so much we can talk about on the
uh that committee or whatever whatever
you want to call it i mean it's a
one-sided show trial like you would see
in a uh a dictatorship in the and you
know there did we get outplayed in sort
of the straight you know the the chess
match of who should have been on the
committee and you know if they wouldn't
put jim jordan should we at least had
some
non-anti-trumpers on this to at least
you know bring a different you know
narrative or a different you know
thrust of the questioning
right now it is um it's the only thing
the left has and that's that's what's
just fascinating to me i mean if you
look at uh what the two things that the
left has is they have uh the dobbs
opinion
uh and and you know essentially claiming
uh making falsehoods about what actually
dobbs is and stands for which is the
overturning of roe v wade and returning
the issue to the people into the states
um but then their other issue is january
6th and and you know and some false
narrative about um
this you know mass conspiracy i i don't
even i don't know what they're trying i
mean they're just trying to destroy
people and and leave they just mass
chaos in its wake they use this
manipulative technique where
you
when when something happens we don't
know at the time of a circumstance what
is happening so uh 911 for example
there's a lot of people who like to look
at footage from 911 and then claim it's
proof of a conspiracy and it's like hold
on the reason you get conflicting
reports in in some of these
circumstances because at the time
everyone was confused as to what was
really going on a guy who was on the
north who was in the financial district
didn't know exactly what was happening
on the upper west side and so people
were getting conflicting information
across the board and thus news reports
come out and they conflict now whatever
you want to believe on that stuff i'm
not getting into the nitty-gritty my
point is on january 6 the people who
were let into the building many of them
had no idea i'd say most of them
probably had no idea there was fighting
happening on the other side cops opened
up the barricades fanned them in doors
were opened cops fanned them in one guy
was acquitted of all charges because of
that that guy did not know that the
other side of the building
couldn't see it people were beating cops
and fighting and throwing things so what
happens is
hindsight the democrats look at the most
egregious moments
show everyone that footage and then say
everybody in that building that's them
right there and people go wow
well and you know what they're also
doing in addition to those 800 and some
people that have been charged uh with
with you know
all sorts of various crimes including
illegal entering of a secured facility
they then say all 1.5 million people are
in washington dc that day or
insurrectionist
i mean you know people that weren't even
close to the capital are you know are
are suddenly swept in and then they've
taken the next logical step which is all
of you trump supporters are are the
equivalent of the people that were you
know assaulting police officers and
that's just right we know that's not
true but you know again there's nobody
on this committee to to give a counter
narrative or to explain exactly what you
just said which is it all depends on
what part of the elephant you're you're
you're
examining yeah i think the fair point is
to be a little bit optimistic is that uh
the only thing they have is january 6
and americans don't care about it at all
yeah i mean you look at gas prices
inflation
people care much much more about that
and the news coming out of there is joe
biden's going to be selling off 20
million more barrels of our strategic
petroleum reserve
gutting the system i think he's doing it
to be honest um because he wants to he
wants europe to be able to buy oil from
us because russia's cutting them off or
fuel i should say russia's cutting off
their gas yeah but if the left was you
know really believed that they needed to
help europe
uh joe biden on day one would have said
to
merkel and angela merkel at the time you
need to keep building those liquid
natural gas terminals uh and really if
they shut down their nuclear power yeah
they've they've done everything to
increase their dependency on russia and
uh the fact that they didn't see this
coming um you know is is naive at the
worst and intentional you know really as
the truth it sounds intentional i think
it sure looks like i can't this is one
of those things that you know i i so my
experience is being a federal prosecutor
uh you know sort of being a you know uh
someone that's run for public office
twice in iowa and so you know my um you
know it's just in israel but you know
sort of the the geo the real politic of
some of these global issues um
you know i apply reason and common sense
and they just it doesn't add up you know
what germany did over the last decade to
end up in this situation with russia i
don't understand but maybe they just
maybe they just nev didn't believe that
russia was and putin was as evil as he
is we had zubi on the other day he said
he thinks it's a controlled demolition
that he sees what's happening it's
intentional and i said you know i'll
give you an example they say there's
going to be a food shortage because of
the war with russia ukraine and russia
aren't exporting wheat anymore russia is
not exporting fertilizer
then the government of the netherlands
tells their farmers to stop farming the
uk and island tell their farmers to stop
farming how does that make sense it
doesn't not at all i wonder if the real
reason they're telling their farmers not
to farm is because they want to reserve
fuel for the war effort or in
preparation for something like that
we got a lot of we got a people people
eat a lot of food we got a major
abundance of food so maybe the thinking
is
tell the farmers oh it's climate change
you got to stop and then what that does
is reduces the amount of consumption uh
fossil fuels of oil they use we could
divert that into other areas maybe i
don't know but i'll tell you this it's
all intentional
that to me is an objective fact you
can't tell people the food shortage is
coming we're all going to starve to
death hey stop farming yeah so you
remember um
oh i don't went 20 years ago when there
was no iphone 20 years ago where you two
2007 15. yeah i mean so so
i mean maybe 10 years ago i don't know
i'm not a technologist but i have an
iphone 2005 six is when there's no okay
that's right okay so less than 20 years
ago and um this is the this is what
surprises me about human beings we're so
innovative we're always trying to to to
solve problems and to make you know life
easier and and to do all these things
and yet you know in an iphone less than
20 years ago we didn't have iphones um
and think about what you can do with an
iphone i mean it's just extraordinary
even though you don't track you and does
everything you know all these insidious
things too but
somehow energy is different than an
iphone that we won't evolve that we
won't you know there won't be new
technologies there won't be better ways
to you know sort of you know
drive tractors and push cars around and
all the all the things we use fossil
fuels for i just i just i i am i believe
in american innovation and and
and especially americans but human
innovation and i think the human humans
are not given enough credit to solve
some of these problems um you know
whether you believe in climate change or
not
um
you you still you know
should be you know we clean energy
makes some sense just as if we want
cleaner cleaner air and clean water it's
as clean as it's been in a long time ben
shapiro makes this point he says all of
these charts talking about the future
due to climate change don't take into
account mitigation efforts yeah or
innovation or innovation yeah the
changes that come like the famous story
of uh they said at the turn of the
century 1900's new york was going to be
covered in mountains of horse crap yup
because there's too many horses too many
people what are we going to do in the
car gets invented and now there's no
horses i think if you're the guy that
had the buggy whip factory i mean your
life was good until all sudden it wasn't
you know and and i and i look at some of
these and that's why we need to make
sure
that we're not i mean we're always
fighting the last war we're always you
know trying to
win the last election um and i think on
some of this we're not
we're not really believing in in the
ability of human beings to solve these
problems
i mean because if we figure out a way or
if someone figures out a way to for
example
uh you know burn hydrogen uh and all of
a sudden you know the output of that is
is um water i mean you know that's i
mean those technologies are coming on
and cars already produce water yeah it's
exhausted right and so
i i don't know i i i just i i really
think uh you know i look at the iphone
and what the revolution of technology in
my life i mean i'm sure i think nobody
here except me probably had an answering
machine oh i have oh i had one okay yeah
all right good yeah yeah yeah
you know but the yeah it was enough
but yeah yeah so i mean i remember
in college
you know you didn't like your your home
phone rang and you got home and you were
excited because it said two or it was
blinking and you pushed it and you
listened to
the calls that it came in since you had
left i mean it was just it was just it's
and now i mean you can't like 24 7
speaking
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there